ونحييكم من جديد تطورات متسارعه توصف
بالتاريخيه عكسها الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني الذي رعته الصين الشهر الماضي
حيث تتجه المؤشرات نحو ان تضع الحرب
المشتعله في اليمن منذ 8 سنوات او زرها
ربما قريبا وكانت انباء العالم العربي
تقول ان المفاوضات في صنعاء بين الحوثيين
والوفدين السعودي والعماني تسير بشكل
طبيعي ووفق جدول الاعمال المتفق عليه
مسبقا بين الوفود المشتركه على الرغم من
وجود بعض النقاط الخلافيه واضافت الوكاله
ان النقاش جاري حاليا حول نقاط الخلافيه
من دون ان تشير الى ماهيه تلك الخلافات
وكان الوفدان السعودي والعماني وصل الى
صنعاء مطلع الاسبوع الحالي لاجراء محادثات
مع الحوثيين وابلغ مصدر مسؤول في الحكومه
اليمنيه وكاله انباء العالم العربي بان
اليمنيين يعاونون على الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني للتواصل الى اتفاق مع الحوثيين
هذه المره
بحسب الوكاله نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا
من لندن بدر القحطاني محرر الملف اليمني
في جريده الشرق الاوسط اهلا بك ومن عدن
العقيد الركن ياسر صالح المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي اهلا بكم الكريمين واسمحالي
ان ابدا طالما نحن نتحدث عن شان اليمني ان
نبدا من داخل اليمن من عدن بتحديد معك
عقيد ياسر عقيد ياسر مع تواتر هذه
المعلومات والبدء باجراءات فعليه من بينها
تبادل الاسرى الى اي مدى حضرتك وانت في
الداخل اليمني تثق في هذا المسار وتعتقد
بانه هناك مرحله جديده تكتب للحرف اليمن
في او بهدفي انهائه على الاقل
لا شك ان الحاله التبشيريه الحادثه في
الساحه
الاقليميه واليمنيه بالتحديد
حول السلام
ومالات السلام في اليمن
توحي بان هنالك تحرك جدي في هذا الاتجاه
هذا التحرك مرتكز على عوامل اقليميه
وعوامل دوليه العوامل الاقليمي وهو تدخل
الصين في
العلاقه السعوديه الايرانيه ورعايتها لهذه
الاتفاقيه العامل الاقليمي وهو التجارب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران وشاهدنا
ايران
كيف
سارعت في عمليه تنفيذ الاتفاقيه سواء في
اللقاء وزيرى الخارجيه سواء في سعيها الى
فتح السفاره واليوم ايضا تصريح ووزير
تجارتها
وبانه سيزور جده خلال الشهر القادم
لتوقي استثماريه اذا دعني اسمي حقيقه ان
هذا المتغير الذي حدث في القضيه اليمنيه
ان اكسير الحياه منح لايران من جديد في
اعاده وضعها الطبيعي في علاجاتها
الاقليميه وبالتالي سينعكس هذا بالتاكيد
على الملف اليمني ولكن نحن امام حاله تؤكد
لنا سواء على المستوى الاقليمي
الطريقه الايرانيه او الطريقه المنهجيه
الحوثيه ايضا المنبثقه من المنهجيه
الايرانيه في التفاوض مع العالم والمجتمع
المحيط به منذ اربعين عام نحن ايضا نعاني
منها منذ قرابه العشرين عام منذ عام 2004
حافه الهاويه ولكن ممكن ان يتم الاتفاق
خلال هذه الزياره على الاطارات
التنفيذيه التي ممكن ان يتم فيها الحوار
ما بين الاطراف اليمنيه ولكن في تصوري ان
الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل وان هنالك
الكثير من التعجيقات التعقيدات المحليه
التي ستفرض خلال عمليه التفاوض ولكن في كل
الاحوال نحن امام سلام وصلنا الى قرابه
العام تحديدا
منذ وقف اطلاق النار ممكن ان يستمر اطلاق
النار ايضا لسته اشهر او لسنه قادمه يتم
في خلالها الحوار ولكن في تصوري هنالك
سلام قادم ولكنه ليس سلاما مستدام خلينا
خلينا نبدا بتفكيك على الاقل ما يجري الان
قبل
الوصول الى مرحله الاطار الذي يمكن ان
يتفاوض من خلاله الطرفان نحن في مرحله
استاذ بدر تبادل اسراء وتعلم حضرتك بانه
الاتفاق تم منذ سنوات ولكن لم يحدث فيه
شيء في كل مره كان هناك اما تواصل او
اخفاق في تحقيق هذه الخطوه ولكن بعد اعلان
الاتفاق المبدئي السعودي الايراني على
عوده العلاقات الطبيعيه بعده بفتره وجيزه
تم تحقيق هذه النقطه وهو تبادل وهنا
السؤال الى اي مدام الطرفان السعوديه
وايران قادران على تفكيك
كل الخلافات الداخليه الحاصله في اليمن
مساء الخير عليك يا اختي ريم وعلى ضيفك
الكريم والساده المشاهدين اعتقد انهم
المهم جدا ان نعي ان هذا الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني لا يستطيع ان ان يحل كافه
المشاكل بسرعه
وبشكل فوري ولكن في المقابل تستطيع
السعوديه التي تتمتع بثقه عاليه من جميع
الفرقاء اليمنيين واخرهم الحوثيين وليس
اولهم
بالاضافه الى ان ايران سواء عن طريق دعمها
المباشر او غير المباشر
للحوثيين سوف تلعب بالتاكيد دورا اذا ما
ارادت دعمها المباشر سيكون عباره عن
الالتزام نقلت جريده عن مصادر تحدثت عن ان
شمخاني قال ان ايران سوف تتوقف عن تزويد
الحوثيين بالاسلحه وهذه نقطه مهمه الدعم
غير المباشر الايراني يتمثل في الدعم
السياسي واللوجسي والاعلامي ايضا فاذا
تحدثنا هذه هنا عن الصوره الاكبر
الصراع نرى ان كبار اللاعبين بداوا
يتوافقون اكثر
فيما يتعلق بالتفاصيل اليمنيه كما تفضل
ضيفكم شيطان للاسف الشديد دائما يخمل في
تفاصيل التفاصيل صحيح وهذه الجمله بدات
تتكررها كل
ضيوف كلهم يتخوفون من هذه التفاصيل وحضرتك
بدات عقيد ياسر في سرد بعض هذه التفاصيل
طيب خلينا نتخيل بانه المسار
بدا يتطور بدا يتقدم وهناك مراحل يمكن ان
نشهدها لتوطيد العلاقه بين الفرقاء
اليمنيين في الداخل تسمعني عقيد ياسر
عقيد ياسر تسمعني
عذرا اعيد السؤال صرت تسمعني الان صوت صوت
واصلك صح
طيب اعود لك بعد قليل ربما هناك انقطاع
على مستوى الصف تفضلي طيب كنت اتحدث منذ
قليل عقيد ياسر على ان شيطان يكمن في
تفاصيل وقلت بانه التفاصيل الداخل اليمني
هي الاصعب طيب فطلبت منك ان نتخيل المراحل
القادمه بعد تبادل الاسرى وهي خطوه جدا
ايجابيه قراها مراقبون بعدها ما الذي يجب
ان ينجز داخل اليمني حتى تستمر هذه الهدنه
وحتى نصل الى مرحله البدء بشكل معين من
السلام الدائم
اتمنى ان تكون استمعت لي على الاقل لاني
اعدت سؤال مرتين عقد ياسر طيب سنترك لك
بعض الوقت اكيد بان الاستاذ بدر استمع على
السؤال لن اعيده فانقل لك نفس هذه النقطه
نفس هذه التفاصيل الخطوه القادمه للبدء
بالعمل على تحقيق السلام كيف ستكون
في البدايه اختي ريم اعتقد ان الحرب في
اليمن بدات في الانقلاب الحوثي عام 2014
واستمرت تسعه اعوام فمن الصعب جدا ان ان
اتخيل ان يكون هناك سلام فوري وان
يحتضن اليمنيون بعضهم بعضا وان يكون
الفرقاء يعني على توافق كبير الجميع يريد
تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه هناك تحديات اقتصاديه
كبيره جدا تفضلتي وقلت اتفاق الاسرى اعتقد
ان اتفاق الاسرى استفاده من الاجواء ولكنه
كان منعقدا قبل حتى ان يتم اعلان الاتفاق
السعودي الايراني برعايه الصينيه ولكنه
ياشي بان المنطقه او ان الازمه اليمنيه
اذا
ركزنا عليها سوف
تستبشر باجواء جيده عن من يستفيد من هذه
الاجواء سوف يكون احد الرابحين والدافعين
نحو السلام انا لا اتخيل ان يكون هناك حتى
بدايه النهايه لم نصل اليها بعد ولكن اود
التركيز على نقطه ان السعوديه كوصيد يتمتع
بثقه جميع الفرقاء اليمنيين قد تدفع هذه
المساله بان تلعب الرياض دور الوسيط بشكل
جيد بحيث تقرب بين الوسطاء وانت تستخدم
نفوذها احيانا اذا لزم الامر مساله
المسوده التي تم تداولها والمدارسات
الموجوده حتى الان هي ما زالت تحت او قيد
النقاش والمفاوضات واعتقد انه من الصعب ان
نناقش ما لم يتم اعلان
خريطه الطريق الاوليه او المسوده الاوليه
او المراحل او المرحله الانتقاليه هناك
العديد من من
المدارسات حول هذه النقطه لكن هناك ثوابت
في نفس الوقت وقت اطلاق النار توحيد البنك
المركزي فتح الموانئ
والمطارات والمرافق وجميع الحدود اليمنيه
سوف يعجل ويدفع ويثري مساله السلام
اليمنيه وبالتالي سنكون على موعد مع
ماراثون طويل جدا اعتقد من المفاوضات
والمشاورات واعتقد ان الجميع يجب ان يحتفظ
بانه كما يحتفظ بمكاسب عليها ان يحتفظ
باوراق التنازلات لانها ضروريه ومطلوبه من
الجميع لكي يتحقق السلام منشود الى اليمن
واليمنيين وان يبداوا نهايه الازمه ويدخل
في مرحله التنميه اعتقد ان اليمن محاط
بجيران لديهم طموحات اقتصاديه كبيره ولا
اعتقد انهم سوف انهم يعون انهم لن يحققوا
المامور وهناك دوله في الجوار غير مستقره
هناك ثمانيه ملايين او اكثر من الطلاب
الذين لم يلتحقوا بالدراسه جي من خلال
اعوام التسعه الماضيه هناك العديد من
اصحاب الاعمال الذين فقدوا تجارتهم هناك
الكثير من رواد الاعمال الذين يريدون وهم
في امس الحاجه الى التمويل الى الشراكه
الى المبيعات فبالتالي نحن
في الاعلان النهائي صحيح هو المسار طويل
في هذا الاطار ونحن سنتابع هذا المراسون
لنفهم كيف سيكون هل هو بهذه الصعوبه او
ستتحلى الاطراف داخل اليمني ببعض من
المرونه كما يرى البعض اود شكركم يا جزيل
الشكر من لندن بدر القحطاني محرر الملف
اليمني في جريده الشرق الاوسط ومن عدانا
العقيد الركنيه صالح المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات